hello and welcome to the new old review
source for everything anime and manga
and today it is finally time to conclude
the reincarnation arc of black clover
because huzzah i did finish it this week
and things certainly escalated to a
level that yeah i wasn't quite expecting
even though escalation beyond
expectations is kind of like tarbeta's
staple move during art climaxes still
finally done and there is a whole done
to go through but before doing so may i
encourage you to reincarnate your
interest in the subscribe button for the
new world review the pressing of which
will grant regular black clover content
uploaded straight into youtube feed as
well as let me know that you want more
of the adventures of a devil child
and friends so we're going to start with
some of the less impactful in retrospect
events of reincarnation because if i
don't get them out now then they're just
going to get lost in a world of devils
and wizard kings plural but where i
picked things up from pretty much throw
straight into a battle against one
dorothy unsworth quite possibly the most
regal and wanky sounding name that we
have been subjected to thus far in the
series but more accurately it was the
elf possessing
dorothy hensworth and gained access to
her very trixie dream magic but this
fight was incredibly enjoyable and very
cleverly structured the team up against
her consisting of vanessa magna lux
sally and of course charmy were an
intriguing combination and i quite
enjoyed that sally got some time to
shine here when she isn't being a mad
dissection enthusiast she's pretty
pleasant and super smart effectively
coming up with the whole like
counter dream strategy which i think was
quite brilliant on the part of tarpita
as well the whole convinced the elf that
the real dorotheon's worth was conjured
and thus
making that a reality very big gambit
but very high reward and afterwards we
also had a nice skirmish between elf
gauche and elf marie versus the
remaining of the black bulls and we got
to explore another cool concept of not
being able to look at your opponent in
battle which yeah i did quite like that
i also really like that tarpitura is
starting to make confrontations like
these centered around an idea it reminds
me a lot of fights in jojo's bizarre
adventure where an enemy stand will
present some ridiculous condition that
can only really be overcome by mental
dissection
stuff like that adds a great layer to
combat and stops it from being
incredibly repetitive basic
mage fighty fights which is very
important in a mega arc like this where
action is effectively
non-stop if these fights didn't present
some very interesting ideas to latch
onto then i think the sark would have
inflicted some very
serious fatigue on me and on top of that
the continued exploration of characters
through mini flashbacks during these
skirmishes are actually quite meaty and
they make me want to stop and take a
moment to really digest what's going on
a bit more now unfortunately for elf
gauche and elf marie
morelf i guess we would call her but no
matter how great their magic combination
was it is still magic and in the words
of the witch queen
before astor all magic is meaningless
although they did still need to work
together and create an opportunity for
him oh and also at one point ghost like
created a disco ball
which is yeah that's kind of funky very
nice use of mirror magic you
party animal after all of that though we
are diving pretty balls deep into the
shadow palace shenanigan where things
just get a little bit wild and i guess
completely unhinged first up though
fuego leon and mario leona make an
impressive entrance as expected and may
i just say i was a fool and utter full
to have assumed that mario leona was
done for in the sock i also found it
pretty funny that she got matched up
against fedo because as soon as i saw
her opponent i was like oh you poor poor
guy you just got reincarnated only to
die again
which he didn't but when you're up
against cisco leon it is more than
likely the two siblings also had this
shared flashback which fleshed out how
much they both respect and admire one
another which stems from an event known
as the tuesday of blood and flames
something i would kill to see but i
enjoyed tarbeta highlighting their
contrast the differing types of strength
and genius where fuego leon is logical
and a calculated man maria leona is an
instinct-driven beast and what's more
both of them recognize each
other as the strongest which is adorable
and no doubt spurs each one of them to
continue to be better in order to reach
their ideal views of the other sibling
but one of many revelations that
occurred in this third
and final third act of the reincarnation
arc surrounds my delightful charmy who
is apparently a human dwarf hybrid and i
was not expecting that or her sudden
glow up but there was something very
beautiful about how her delightful
bountiful food chip was transformed into
a hungry hungry wolf you know because of
the whole wolf in sheep's clothing thing
in just about every story surrounding
wolves and sheep they're very much
natural opposites like brits and
australians or new zealanders and
australians or australians and
other australians whatever the case
charmi continues to be a strong favorite
of mine and if it wasn't for the whole
you know obsession i think she'd be
pretty perfect
speaking of you know did i read
something wrong or is you know pregnant
there was an awful lot of talk about
having licks child inside of you know
during the sock and i suppose
congratulations are in order i mean i
assume that this
means that the elf soul that
reincarnated within yuno was the child
of licht which i suppose is very
potentially how yunna was able to quite
easily resist
being taken over by an elvish persona it
also at least narratively explains why
asta didn't use the reincarnation buster
on yuno back in the village it still
doesn't
logically explain it though thinking
back on it there is still no reason and
it feels like a terrible idea not to
vanquish the elf threat within you know
when you had such an easy opportunity to
do so but in this arc you know is also
referred to quite blatantly as the
destined one which is interesting i
suppose another very strong line and a
hint of
lines or a line of hints i should say
that you know is not of common heritage
like asta and the rest of their village
but as for moving on it's pretty
impossible to do so without mentioning
the devil well hey devil i guess so
tabitha did the uh the thing he does
where it turns out that the character
set up to be the main antagonist is
actually a red herring for a third act
twist this twist turned out to be the
most bizarre and sinister yet as it
turns out a
literal devil is responsible for i guess
all of the bad things and i have some
mixed feelings on that
on the one hand i do like delving into
this other world of existence the devil
of astor's grimoire has always intrigued
me and it's fun to know that they're
part of
i think what i think is a different race
maybe in fact asta's devil even made an
appearance to taunt his elder towards
the end of the arc which was
pretty fun and in terms of design i will
give tarbita all of the credit in the
world maybe not all of it some of it i
will give him some of the credit in the
world for making our enemy devil
simultaneously sleek and cool but also
quite legitimately difficult to look at
at the same time every time the devil
was shown the art has this very
disturbing quality about it and it makes
me actively not want to linger on it for
too long which definitely isn't a bad
thing i really like it actually because
it makes the devil feel like an
abominable otherworldly existence which
is exactly what i think he is
the part i don't like about the devil is
that his existence really does
kind of dumb down the issues in this arc
and in fact all of black clover to this
point since this is a series climax most
darks have really been building up to
this really intense hatred of humanity
from the elves and making me wonder well
just what did humans do to deserve it
because humans in this series do
kind of suck they're selfish
discriminatory and there are more than a
few that are just plain disgusting so to
me it does seem like a bit of a cop-out
answer that we discover
no humanity was perfect all along and it
was just that pesky devil that ruined
everything
which is tragic in its own way because
he has to turn these races against each
other but it's kind of lame and fails to
properly grapple with the themes that
black clover has been setting up rather
well although if anything it is a larger
representation of the reincarnation arc
as a whole with the whole elves taking
over human bodies so you know the humans
aren't responsible and they don't have
to reckon with their elvish actions and
in a grander way now nobody is
responsible for anything and this was
just a stereotypically evil entity that
ruined peace on earth in fact with this
in mind at the moment humans are
portrayed as almost a kind of symbol of
purity while the elves well they defiled
themselves and i really do wish that it
had been the actions of humans alone
that sparked the elf hatred and the both
of these races were very much in the
wrong and then you know needing to come
together to work out their issues i like
more grounded situations like that
because they give you something to take
away whereas if the reason why everyone
did bad things was because of magic
devils and there's nothing i can really
take away from that other than huh
damn that well that sucks doesn't it on
the other hand on a positive note mr
devil son did have some pretty cool
magic to play with the word soul magic
is a very nice concept and it made me
realize why tarbeta had gone to the
effort to show that battle with dorothy
yeah the dream magic user because they
are very similar styles of magic just
being able to conjure anything you want
into existence although the devil was on
an entirely different level but the
dream magic was a gentle step towards
the insanity of the devil who for being
a being who could essentially speak
anything into existence seemed really
fond of making super basic swords and
spears and stuff but there was also a
nice explanation of how the five leaf
groomers were born which
was very cool great idea whenever the
owner of a four-leaf grimar is engulfed
by despair it twists and corrupts into a
new entity one in which devils can
seemingly
infiltrate there's some nice thor there
and also the potential of some future
danger for our current four-leaf
criminal holders and we have now
sort of solved the mystery of astor's
grimoire it was previously lit and
transformed after the
the bad devil event but like the real
vicks not partry and not william who are
also attributed to being licked at some
point
and can i be honest i still don't know
who part tree is and i have to ask am i
supposed to honestly the worst thing
about this entire arc is
anything to do with licked i kind of
despise how convoluted everything
becomes simply in relation to that name
whether it's body sharing body swapping
impersonating
or whatever whenever licked pops up i
have to fight real hard to stay mentally
checked in
because i just don't care and that's a
big problem because in this arc the like
actual licht does make an appearance as
well and i don't even know what to think
about who this man is the road to
actually meeting him has been paved with
very questionable stones and sometimes
holes
just blatant holes and i don't think it
had the effect on me that tarbita
intended because when any of licht patri
or william appears i just see this
gigantic blur of elf weirdness
i have no strong opinion on any one of
them to me they're all just they're
there
and they will continue to be just there
because william came back from his
endless sleep like i think i flagged on
the last video that was possible but
even part tree remained alive but did an
artificial licked body hooray
as did the three main dude bras reya
vetto and
second fauna second fauna there are now
two faunas that are just
alive in this world that's wonderful and
it's just
very interesting when none of your main
antagonists die because it makes me feel
like we got out of this very long
very intense series climax with no real
consequences for anyone whatsoever and
speaking of
i knew it i didn't want it to happen but
the wizard king is alive so the very
last page i've read reveals that he
stored up some
times and has now been revived as a 13
year old boy so look there are
consequences
sort of i mean he has to go through
puberty again that's a consequence
and i'm assuming that julius won't be
quite the magical powerhouse that he was
as an adult although who knows and don't
take this the wrong way because i love
his character but
he should be dead seeing stuff like this
reminds me of a quote from eduardo the
mangaka of one piece because in a 2019
interview he stated i hate the revival
of the dead if a mangaka ends up
reviving the dead then they shouldn't
have killed that character in the first
place with that said oda is also a
pretty gigantic hypocrite because he
frequently revives characters that he
gave
death scenes in the series but i still
very much agree with the sentiment and
it's disappointing to see another great
death scene in media rendered
retrospectively bankrupt i should
probably wait a little bit longer to
reserve full judgement because
maybe this comes with more consequences
for julius and i'm aware of but given
everything else
probably not and i keep thinking of what
might have been a good potential
workaround if he had to be reincarnated
and the only thing i can land on is if
he got reincarnated as like an old man
with 13 years left to live rather than a
13 year old child with a whole life
ahead of him so to summarize my thoughts
on this matter
meh onwards to nero now and it turns out
my favorite little burb is actually a
500 year old
devil lolly and that's that's pretty
cool isn't it although i have to say i
was pretty stunned when i saw nero speak
for the first time it was a very
wide-eyed
war at moment and i didn't really even
get to take it in because then we were
immediately taken to the first wizard
king this i thought was a great way to
solve the situation that tarbeta had
kind of gotten himself into this crazy
powerful devil that maybe can't be
touched by anyone
except the age-old talent of our first
wizard king or at least that's how i
thought it would go down it turns out
astor and yuno played much more of a
central role there and yami let's not
forget yami
ever he was there and he took a lot of
the glory at the end as per usual but i
did like the twist of involving the
first wizard king whose name is lumiere
another light focused name like licht it
was done in a great way though i can see
something like this feeling quite
quite grinch but tabitha i do think
succeeded here although i do want a
proper explanation for as to
why nero became a bird because as of
right now the quote we have is for some
reason
i had been transformed into a bird so we
went all rise of skywalker there you
know
somehow palpatine returned as a whole
experience so i'm really glad that i did
not read the reincarnation arc all in
one go there's just so much to digest
and i'm pretty happy with the choice to
experience it over three weeks or so i
think a lot would get lost in a single
session and it was really a compelling
story and yeah i'm a bit annoyed by the
lack of consequences or overall impact
of it and at the moment it really does
feel like we went through
all of this for nothing and we've ended
up with a net zero position but to be
fair it was a very fun-filled journey to
get to said position with a lot of
fantastic moments for everyone we've met
up until this point and there are a lot
of characters who come out of this like
noel or henry has completely
reinvigorated existences
and so we shall do nothing but look
forward to the next dark but that pretty
much does it for this blind review of
part three of the reincarnation arc and
what do you guys think please leave your
thoughts in the comments below or even
join my discord server and if you're
keen for some more black clover content
then please do go and check out some of
my other videos or even subscribe to the
channel for very maybe regular black
clover goodness delivered straight into
your youtube feed but for now this has
been the new world review and i'll see
you next time